Great to welcome back to the program today,
Don Jeffries, who's incorporated a life of
experience in different areas into many different
books, including Survival of the Richest,
which we previously discussed, and most recently,
Buli ocracy, which is so relevant in so many
ways right now.
It's great to have you back on the program.
Oh, thanks.
It's great to be back, David.
So let I know that look, let's not dance around
the fact that this conversation is very relevant
to Donald Trump, but we don't have to talk
about Trump, at least not not initially.
What is your understanding of why certain
kids end up becoming bullies?
Well, I think that there is a.
And I cite in the book I go there was a study
out of England that discovered that basically
the traits we see in every bully are psychopathic
type traits.
Many of them are.
And unfortunately, our society is ruled largely
by psychopaths.
And if you look at the occupations where psychopathic
personalities are predominant, they're all
the highest paid professions doctors, lawyers,
CEOs, athletes, entertainers, clergymen, policemen,
things like that, which policemen really like
to be successful with.
They have power terms.
So this is when we look at success.
A successful person is indistinguishable often
from a bully.
They trample on people on the way up.
They are they.
That's how they get their way.
And as long as they win.
You look in the sports world, certainly all
the best coaches, virtually every one of the
most successful coaches have bullying characteristics.
And as long as they win, that's fine.
If they don't win, well, there's a problem
and they bring next coach on.
But I think our society pays lip service to
the fact that we like a kindness or whatever,
but we don't.
I mean, clearly, it's a kindness and empathy
are looked at as weak characteristics or aggressiveness
and being able to confront somebodies power,
especially in any kind of power.
These are the qualities that we admire and
everything about our culture.
And certainly the business world says that.
Now, there must be, I'm guessing, a sort of
circumstantial aspect to this as well.
I mean, in other words, there must be something
about the circumstances in which all those
who might find themselves predisposed to bullying
would find themselves in some.
Based on the actual reality, they're living
may become bullies and some may not.
Right.
Sure.
Well, I think it might be the reason why my
book is different is, as the subtitle says,
I believe it's a social hierarchy that enables
bullies.
And that's why I'm you know, I criticize the
school systems, especially because this is
where bullying is born.
And I don't believe they do anything really
to weed out the bullies because they're not
talking about how it's just recent research
that has shown us in the past.
You know, we kind of have that stereotype.
Well, the kid is a bully.
Maybe he's his father's beating him and he's
lashing out at the world.
There's alcoholism there.
Maybe it's a single mother not watching him
living in a trailer park in poverty or something.
That's not the case.
Overwhelmingly, the bullies are the popular
crowd and especially in the sports world.
And we see the jocks bullying the nerdy types
or whatever the Goth crowd.
And that's the dynamic you see in every school
system.
And because of the importance that is placed
on sports, you know, it's ironic that these
we send our kids to school.
And I know it should be theoretically that
the kids who were most successful in school
are those who get the best grades, because
that's why you're going there, right?
That's not the case.
Very seldom are the is the class valedictorian
a popular kid unless they also happen to be
an athlete, which they could be, especially
females.
A lot of the mean girl types do very well
and have, you know, their national honor society
and things like that.
But it's because they don't want to approach
the topic of popularity, because if you have
a concept of popular, everybody knows certain
kids are popular.
You have to have a contrasting unpopular.
There's no such thing as beauty if you don't
have ugliness to contrast it with.
So I think that is the problem, that those
trenchcoat mafia types have to exist in order
for the popular crowd to be basically celebrities
in their school that I documented in the book
over and over again.
As you know, that these school systems from
the teacher to to the principals of the superintendent,
to the local media, to law enforcement, most
of the time they always pooh pooh the claims.
They sweep them under the table.
Your parents will go over and over again to
the school systems.
Name the people who are bullying their child.
Sometimes physically, nothing is done about
it.
And a lot of times I've talked to I talked
to too many parents whose kids killed themselves.
They were bully sighted from it.
And even afterwards, a lot of the anti-bullying
groups even will still say no.
It's more complex than that.
Even when they in their suicide notes, they'll
say, I did this because of bullying or they'll
sometimes even name the actual bullies.
They still try to sweep that under the rug.
And I think that's the problem is they're
not addressing it correctly.
And instead they have these kind of nonsensical
zero tolerance and no bully.
And those schools, as I point out, actually
have more bullying in them than the places
that don't advertise that.
So I think it's a complex issue, but I don't
think anybody until I book it was looking
at the right at the right culprit here, which
I think is the social hierarchy, which creates
and enables bullies to talk a little bit about
the social hierarchy.
I remember back when I was in elementary school,
middle school and high school where the the
popular kids and the bullies were of varied
economic backgrounds.
In other words, you had that they were like
the rich kids and poor kids and whatever you
it really kind of a mix.
More recently, I've talked to a lot of different
people who work in school systems in different
parts of the country, particularly in suburban
settings.
Now, this may be different in urban settings
or rural, but what a lot of them report is
that they see that the not necessarily the
bullies, but the popular kids tend to be the
richest kids.
How how does that play?
Is that a broader phenomenon?
And how does that play into the bullying?
Sure.
I think there's a lot of crossover between
this book and my book, Survival of the Richest,
since you talked about before, because it's
certainly wealth has its perks everywhere.
And if you're if you're if you're a Potter
kid who comes from wealth, you're going to
dress better.
You're going to have the latest accouterments.
You're going to have the latest iPad or whatever,
your latest cell phone, those kinds of things.
You're going to have access to things that
are going to make you seem better.
And kids are going to hang around with you
because maybe you live in a nicer house.
Maybe you have a big swimming pool in your
backyard.
So, of course, maybe, maybe your parents will
pay for their friends to go to some concert
or whatever.
I mean, all these things are possible there.
Whereas if a kid is not wealthy, they might
not have a cell phone or like they have a
crappy old cell phone or something.
And it's just it's like anything else.
It's it's that's why looks are so important.
I talk a lot about that there.
Is it the way you can trump economics is to
be really.
Looking, no, no.
A girl from the other side of the tracks,
that just is really gorgeous.
I don't think too many people are gonna be
making fun of her economic circumstances.
You know, I.
This is something I think that, again, we
don't we don't look at.
But there I think there's a lot of crossover
there.
And I think that not and I've I've been reminded
many times what I wrote this book.
It's not to say that every popular kid.
I mean, I've I was interviewed once by girls
and I was a homecoming queen.
I said I'm not saying everybody that is popular
is a bully, but I think the vast majority
of those bullies happen to be popular.
And I especially the cases that are addressed
by the teachers and principals and superintendents
that are not addressed logically.
I think it's because of that popularity.
I'll give you a perfect example that I cite
in the book.
There was a viral video a couple years ago
that where the guy went to a middle aged man,
went to his his local scorebook school board
meeting, and he wanted to talk about the bullying
that were going on in the local high school.
He said, you know, I went there twenty five
years ago, whatever it was.
And he said, you know, it was it was there
that and he pointed the finger at the school
superintendent and he said, you were the one
who led the bullying against me.
You're the one who stuffed my head in the
urinal.
Things like and it's shocking to see the little
stupid grin the superintendent gets on his
face.
I mean, instantly, you could see he got like
a memory jolt and he was exposed, but he just
can't walk.
I'll tell you, you know, and he's kind of
laughed and but you could see it coming back.
Now, who knows how many other school superintendents
were bullies.
So it's certainly in that school district
where we're and it will any claims of bullying
be taken seriously if the guy in charge was
a vicious bully?
And I think we don't know how many people
are like that.
I have a whole section in the book where I
talk about all the high profile people in
our society is where from actors to actors,
the entertainment world, CEOs, just people
that have politicians.
And it's astonishing how many of them were
the overwhelming majority were popular in
school.
And so it's just if we look at it like I think
the group Bowling for Soup had a song called
High School Never Ends.
And I think that's kind of the way it is where
that crowd.
Not all of them.
And they're their Bill Gates people out there,
of course, outliers.
But there if you look at I mean, people don't
know Woody Allen, for instance, the quintessential
nerd, was actually a great high school baseball
basketball player.
So, you know, if you could guess that Rosie
O'Donnell was her homecoming queen.
So it's not a lot of times we'll look at it
and people don't realize.
And so I think there are ready.
The social hierarchy was very good to them.
And certainly the Fortune 500 cuts are the
overwhelming majority.
These people went to the high profile fraternities,
which I talk about the book.
That's where out of high school you go to
college and it's the fraternities and sororities,
the Greek life.
That's where you see the next step in building
those clicks.
And, of course, that turns into a business.
Business clicks because those people go into
high profile jobs at their fraternity brothers.
And again, it it's this kind of corruption
that we I write about everywhere else we see
these kind of clicks for.
And people that weren't in those fraternities
don't have a chance to get in there.
And so I think it's it's a very complex issue.
But the fact that it's not addressed it at
the school level, I think is the most important
thing.
And all we're asking is that, you know, somebody,
especially when you're bragging about it and
saying you have zero tolerance, if somebody
comes to you, it's pretty clear cut.
If somebody comes to you and I describe in
the book, there were there was a little girl
that came up from kindergarten, one kindergarten
that looked like she'd been 15 rounds in the
ring with Mike Tyson and her mother and actually
wanted an explanation.
The school said she fell and the girl said,
no, this little girls.
But this other girls, men pick it.
I mean, she pushed me off the slide.
So, you know, if that's happening in kindergarten
and somebody is covering up, I don't even
know what that explanation is.
But certainly they need to look at the teachers
who are the first line of defense here that
the first person, the first people that could
theoretically stop it.
Yeah, and I and the principals who aren't
backing them up.
And then the superintendents and I describe
many, many cases over and over again.
You know, readers heads will sway.
I'm looking at it.
But it's always the same story went over and
over and over again.
They did nothing about it.
In worst case scenarios, my child kills himself
afterwards.
They continue to demonize that.
They infer maybe it was us.
You know, the family there were, you know,
may be your fault and they still don't claim
any responsibility.
So it's a huge issue.
And in the limited time we have left on, when
we look at some of the behavior we've seen
from Donald Trump, which includes certainly
bullying people on social media and directing
ire at specific individuals.
The irony of Malani is anti-bullying campaign.
While the behavior of her husband is completely
antithetical to that, we've since learned
about some of some elements of Donald Trump's
upbringing, including that his dad, at minimum,
was virt verbally abusive, that there was
this attitude of never apologized for anything,
never admit that you're wrong, which we've
seen Donald Trump take up.
What do you make of all of that?
Because as you said, it's not always as simple
as, oh, the bully is a bully because they're
getting bullied at home.
But what do you make of the Trump story?
Well, that could have played into part there,
and it could just be again, he comes from
great wealth.
As my friend Gerald Cilenti likes to say.
He was born on third base and thinks he hit
a home run.
Right.
There's so many so many of these guys do that.
So he somebody like Trump led a life of privilege
his entire life.
He was born to the silver spoon in his mouth.
So there was it's hard to be humble under
those circumstances, not his case.
He appears to have had a very weird family
dynamic.
His mother was, I think, probably just as
strange as his father, if you know.
And so, I don't know.
I think somebody said once that nobody had
ever told them that they loved him in his
life.
And certainly it looked away kind of trades
and supermodel wives every 20 years.
I don't think he's ever really looked for
love.
He's looking for a new model.
So I think he's he's kind of the quintessential
superficial guy, the ultimate materialist
guy.
And his personality, unfortunately, is perfect
for our burgeoning idiocracy that we have
now.
I mean, he's basically in many ways, he's
like President Camacho, if you've seen the
movie Idiocracy.
I mean, he's got the WWE personality and he
has what has happened is he has lowered the
level discourse and everybody has joined him.
It's a huge food fight.
So you have the other side tries to bully
him and they're always down in the gutter.
They're calling each other names.
And that's that's what it's trying to do.
It it's a it's a shame, but it's not surprising
because, you know, people knowing of Trump's
personality has been out there for a long
time.
You listen to some of the interviews with
Howard Stern stuff.
He's he's real.
What was different is the populous rhetoric
that a lot of us were attracted to during
his campaign.
I mean, that was came out of nowhere.
Yeah.
You know, but no.
But his personality is.
But it's always been packaged in that personality.
And I say it because he has really attacked
constantly.
And if he had a any kind of a sympathetic
personality, I think a lot of people would
feel sorry for him because he has a tap, but
he just doesn't have any of that.
And he lacks this.
And it's unfortunate that that's you know,
I wrote a whole little section and Billy ocracy
about the emergence of Trump and it's.
It's fitting and you're certainly, like you
said, his what his wife has an anti-bullying
message, but we see that a lot of the football
players where they'll put people like Russell
Wilson of the Seahawks who admits what a big
bully he was in school.
You know, he says, I used to rub kids nose
of the dirt and stuff, and he runs an anti-bullying
organization.
Maybe he's reformed.
And a lot of these football players are in
charge or sponsor these organizations.
And my contention is that football especially
breeds this bullying because it's, you know,
it's manliness and toughness.
And, you know, if you're going against stadia,
you know, you're just naturally you coming
up against the theater crowd, which, you know,
may have gays in it or whatever, just not
macho guys or whatever.
It's it's got to be natural.
So those football players come up and bump
against them and just, you know, do what they
do.
And it's it's it but it's because the schools
play so much more emphasis on sports than
they do at academics or anything else.
And we see in society the role that sports
plays in our lives in sports plays a tremendous
amount.
Look at all the money that that goes into
it with the corporate welfare that I talked
about in survival, the richest the most egregious
example that are all the stadiums that taxpayers
build, NFL stadiums, especially in MLB stadiums
that are paid for completely.
And it's because the those fans that fan bases
know, please don't move our team.
Right.
We'll pay for it.
And so I think it's it's but again, people
don't they don't want to equate sports with
bullying because, I mean, I'm a huge sports
fan.
I played sports at Kote Sports.
I love sports, but I recognize how it breeds
this kind of behavior, especially when it's
not held into account.
Yeah.
And to be clear, there are gay football players
as well.
Not that you were suggesting that that, of
course, the latest book is Bully Ocracy.
We've been speaking with Donald Jeffery's.
Don, always great speaking to you.
I appreciate your time.
Thanks so much for me.